HOLIDAY.
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US
TONIGHT.
HOUSE MAJORITY LEADER KEVIN Mc
CARTHY.
APPARENTLY THE ONLY PERSON LEFT
ON CAPITOL HILL.
CONGRESSMAN.
HERE WE ARE.
YOU SHOULD BE STUFFING STOCKING
AT HOME AND HANG IN THE
MISTLETOE, AND ALL THE FUN STUF
YOU DO IN CALIFORNIA, BUT HERE
WE ARE, THE GOVERNMENT WILL SHU
DOWN IN TWO HOURS.
DID YOU ALL WAIT TOO LONG?
>> I DON'T KNOW WILL WE DID YOU
LONGER THE HOUSE IS VASTLY
FUNDING.
THE CHALLENGE REALLY LIES, AND
THIS IS WHAT THE VIEWERS HAVE T
UNDERSTAND, THE HOUSE TO PASS A
BILL THAT PROTECTS AND SECURES
THE BORDER.
THE SENATE TAKES 60 VOTES FOR I
WHEN I COMES THE QUESTION OF
SHUTTING DOWN IT COMES TO
SCHUMER.
DOES SCHUMER MAKE A DECISION TO
SHUT DOWN OR NOT.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT SHUTDOWN THAN THOSE I
THE PAST BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY
FUNDED THREE QUARTERS OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN IT COMES TO DEFENSE,
MILITARY MEN AND WOMEN AND
OTHERS ARE ALL TAKEN CARE OF,
BUT THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT TO LE
KEEP GOING.
WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING ALONG
THE BORDER.
THINK ABOUT WHAT SCHUMER SAID A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
PROVIDES MONEY FOR THE BORDER,
BUT HE'S AFRAID IT WOULD AFFECT
NANCY PELOSI IS VOTE FOR SPEAKER
.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
BACK IN OCTOBER, YOU AND I
TALKED ABOUT THIS AT THE TIME.
WHEN PAUL RYAN SAID WERE GOING
TO DO THIS ARE GOING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO HAVE W
ALL KNEW THAT WAS RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN YOU WERE NOT IN THAT CAMP
, BUT FOR TWO YEARS PAUL
RYAN, AND EVERYONE HERE SAYS
THIS I LIKE HIM VERY MUCH AS A
PERSON, HE HAS NOT BEEN ON THE
PRESIDENT SIDE ON THIS WALL.
HE NEVER WANTED A WALL.
HE NEVER BELIEVED IN THE WALL.
HE DIDN'T LIKE IT.
HE DIDN'T LIKE A LOT OF WHAT
TRUMP WAS SAYING ABOUT THE WALL.
HERE WE ARE ON THE 11th HOUR
AND IT'S ALL ON TERMS SHOWERS.
I FIND IT OUTRAGEOUS.
I HAD TO TELL YOU, I KNOW YOU
AND GOOD FRIENDS.
ON TELEVISION BLAMING FOX NEWS
AND BASICALLY TALK RADIO.
>> SOME RIGHT WING PEOPLE
YELLING AT YOU ON FOX NEWS AND
SUDDENLY HE SAYS WELL, I DON'T
THINK I'M GOING TO SIGN IT.
IT'S VERY TRUE THAT HE HELPED
BRING ON THE SHUTDOWN AND NEEDS
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT.
ANY EFFORT TO BLAME DEMOCRATS
WE'LL BE LEAP.
>> SHE USED THE BS WORD.
IF THIS OF RIGHT WING BRENDAN
SHUTDOWN OR DID THE PRESIDENT
SAY IT'S DO OR DIE.
>> THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON
THIS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS GOING
TO FIGHT FOR THIS WALL.
IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO TAKING
60 VOTES IN THE SENATE.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING WHAT HE
PROMISED GETTING TAX REFORM.
THE PRESIDENT IS A FIGHTER.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THAT PAUL HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR THE WALL AS
WELL.
MAYBE NOT AT THE RIGHT TIMES,
BUT HERE WE ARE IN THIS FIGHT
AND BLOOD TASTE CHANGE THIS WEE
REMEMBER WHEN NANCY PELOSI WAS
LATER SHE LOOKED TO THE
PRESIDENT AND SAID YOU DON'T
HAVE THE VOTES IN THE HOUSE.
WE OVERWHELMINGLY PROVE THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
WE HAVE SENT THE BILL NOW TO TH
SENATE.
SO IT REALLY LIES WITH THE
SENATE AND THE CHALLENGE THERE
AS YOU WATCH THE VOTE, IT COMES
DOWN TO WHAT SCHUMER HAS FOR
POWER.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S
UNFORTUNATE FOR AMERICA.
THAT'S WHEN STILL WORK RIGHT NOW
.
>> AGAIN, I BEG TO DIFFER I
THINK PAUL RYAN COULD'VE GOTTEN
THE VOTES FOR THE BILL.
HE CAME WITHIN 13 VOTES OF
PASSING THAT.
I THINK IT COULD HAVE HAPPENED